find the equation of a line
perpendicular
to
this line that passes through the point
two comma eight so this first piece of
information that it's perpendicular to
that line right over there what does
that tell us well if it's perpendicular
to this line its slope has to be the
negative inverse of two-fifths so its
slope the negative inverse of two-fifths
the inverse of two-fifths is
five let me do it in a better color a
nicer green
if this line's slope is negative
two-fifths the equation of the line we
have to figure out that's perpendicular
its slope is going to be the inverse so
instead of two-fifths is going to be
five-halves instead of being a negative
it's going to be a positive so this is
the negative inverse of negative
two-fifths right you take the negative
sign it becomes positive you swap the
five and the two you get five halves so
that is going to have to be our slope
and we can actually use the point-slope
form right here it goes through this
point right there so let's use point
slope form
y
minus
this y value which has to be on the line
is equal to our slope
five halves times x minus this x value
the x value when y is equal to 8.
and this is the equation of the line in
point-slope form if you want to put it
in
slope-intercept form you can just do a
little bit of algebra
algebraic manipulation y minus 8 is
equal to let's distribute the 5 halves
so 5
halves x
minus 5 halves times 2 is just 5
and then add 8 to both sides you get y
is equal to 5 halves x
add 8 to negative 5 so plus 3
and we are done